well you've built quite a few PCS what's
your advice on how to build a good
custom PC
for uh let's say for the different
applications that you use for gaming for
uh machine learning well you shouldn't
build one you should buy a box from the
tiny Corp
I heard rumors Whispers
about this box in the tiny Corp what's
what's this thing look like what it what
is it what is it called it's called the
Tiny Box Tiny Box um it's fifteen
thousand dollars and it's almost a paid
a flop of compute it's over 100
gigabytes of GPU Ram it's over five
terabytes per second of GPU memory
bandwidth
uh I'm gonna put like four nvmes in in
raid you're gonna get like 20 30
gigabytes per second of Drive read
bandwidth
I'm gonna I'm gonna build like
the best deep learning box that I can
that plugs into one wall outlet
okay can you go through those specs
again a little bit from your from memory
yeah so it's almost a paid a flop of
compute so in D Intel today I'm leaning
toward AMD
um but we're pretty agnostic to the type
of compute
the the main limiting spec is a 120 volt
15 amp circuit
okay well I mean it because in order to
like like there's a plug over there all
right
you have to be able to plug it in
um we're also going to sell the tiny
rack which like what's the most power
you can get into your house without
arousing suspicion uh and one of the one
of the answers is an electric car
charger wait where does the rag go your
garage
interesting the car charger a wall
outlet is about 1500 watts a car charger
is about 10 000 Watts
what is the most amount of power you can
get your hands on without a rousing
suspicion that's right George Haas okay
uh so the the Tiny Box and you said
nvme's and raid uh I forget what you
said about memory all that kind of stuff
okay so uh what about what gpus again
probably probably 7 900 xdx's but maybe
30 90s maybe a770s those are Intel
you're flexible or still exploring I'm
still exploring I wanna I wanna deliver
a really good experience to people and
yeah what gpus I end up going with again
I'm leaning toward AMD we'll see you
know in my email what I what I said to
AMD is like just dumping the code on
GitHub is not open source open source is
a culture
open source means that your issues are
not all one-year-old style issues open
source means developing in public and if
you guys can commit to that I see a real
future for AMD as a competitor doing
video
well I'd love to get a tiny boxed MIT so
whenever it's ready well done let's do
it we're taking pre-orders I took this
from Elon I'm like a hundred dollar
fully refundable pre-orders is it going
to be like the Cyber truck it's going to
take a few years or no I'll try to do it
faster it's a lot simpler it's a lot
simpler than a truck well there's
complexities not to just the
uh putting the thing together but like
shipping and all this kind of stuff the
thing that I want to deliver to people
out of the box is being able to run 65
billion parameter llama in fp16 in real
time in like a good like 10 tokens per
second or five tokens per second or
something just it works job was running
uh or something like llama experience
yeah or I think Falcon is is the new one
experience a chat with the largest
language model that you can have in your
house
yeah from from a wall plug from a wall
plug yeah actually for inference it's
not like even more power would help you
get more
the biggest model released is is 65
billion parameter llama as far as I know
so it sounds like Tiny Box will
naturally uh pivot towards company
number three because you could just get
the girlfriend
and uh I mean or boyfriend
that one's harder actually the boyfriend
is harder boyfriend's harder yeah I
think that's a very biased statement I
know a lot of people just say what's
what why is it harder to replace a
boyfriend than the other girlfriend with
the artificial llm because women are
attracted to status and power and men
are attracted to Youth and beauty
no I mean that's what I mean both are
mimicable easy to the language model no
no machines do not have any status or
real power I don't know I think you both
well first of all you're using language
mostly uh to
to communicate Youth and beauty and
power and status but status
fundamentally is a zero some game
right where is Youth and beauty or not
no I think status is a narrative you can
construct I I don't think status is real
I don't know I just think that that's
why it's harder you know yeah maybe it
is my biasis I think status is way
easier to fake I also think that you
know men are probably more desperate and
more likely to buy my product so maybe
they're a better target market
desperation is interesting easier to
fool that's I could I could see that
yeah look I mean look I know you can
look at porn viewership numbers right a
lot more men watch porn than women yeah
that's why that is
well there's a lot of questions and
answers you can get there
anyway with the with the Tiny Box how
many gpus in Tiny Box six
[Laughter]
oh man and I'll tell you why it's sex
yeah uh so AMD epic processors have 128
Lanes of pcie
um I want to leave enough lanes for
some uh drives and I want to leave
enough lanes for some networking
how do you do cooling for something like
this Ah that's one of the big challenges
not only do I want the cooling to be
good I want it to be quiet I want the
Tiny Box to be able to sit comfortably
in your room right this is really going
towards the girlfriend thing because you
want to run the llm I'll give I'll give
them more I mean I can talk about how it
relates to company number one
comma AI yeah well but yes quite oh
quiet because you maybe potential one
around in a car no no quiet because you
want to put this thing in your house and
you want it to coexist with you if it's
screaming it's 60 DB you don't want that
in your house you'll kick it out 60 DB
yeah yeah I'm only like 40 45. so how do
you make the cooling uh quiet that's an
interesting problem in itself um a key
trick is to actually make it big
ironically it's called the Tiny Box yeah
but if I can make it big a lot of that
noise is generated because of high
pressure air if you look at like a 1u
server a 1u server has these super high
pressure fans they're like super deep
and they they're like Genesis versus if
you have something that's big well I can
use a big and you know you know they
call them Big Ass Fans those ones that
are like huge on the ceiling and they're
completely silent so tiny box
will be big
it is the uh I do not want it to be
large according to UPS I want it to be
shippable as a normal package but that's
my constraint there
interesting well the the fans stuff it
can't can't it be assembled on location
or no no
it has to be well you're you're look I
want to give you a great out of the box
experience I want you to lift this thing
out I want it to be like like the Mac
you know
Tiny Box the Apple experience yeah
I love it okay and so tiny box would run
tiny grad like what what what do you
envision this whole thing to look like
we're talking about like
uh Linux with a full
software engineering environment
and just not pie torch but tiny grad
yeah we did a poll if people want Ubuntu
or Arch we're going to stick with Ubuntu
oh interesting what's your favorite uh
flavorful
I like Ubuntu mate however you
pronounced that meat
so how do you uh you've gotten llama
into tiny grad you've gotten stable
diffusion this Italian grind what was
that like